[Music]
the lightsaber one of the most famous
visual effects of all time and the way
that this effect has been achieved has
evolved over the years from the original
analog rotoscoping to digital tools that
made this so much easier now modern
lightsabers have leds inside of the
blade to emit light allowing us to get a
little bit of that lightsaber effect in
camera but as you can see it's a tube of
light and it's kind of lifeless it still
requires an artistic touch to punch it
up and make it look like a sick
lightsaber
but did you know for the original star
wars movie they invented an actual way
to get this effect done entirely in
camera and it worked
but they abandoned it
so fine in this video i'm gonna dig up
those blueprints and i'm gonna build one
myself
[Applause]
so what was the original lightsaber made
out of well the original lightsaber was
actually literally taken from cameras
like the big flashbulb photography stuff
using this design they essentially took
a motor that could spin and attach to
that motor was a rod that would also
spin remember this was the 70s they
didn't have led technology back then so
they couldn't have luke holding some
sort of powerful light source to look
like a lightsaber what they could do
however was bounce a light off of it
using retroreflective tape now what is
retroreflective tape well it's a type of
material that's got like a bunch of
micro glass beads and whatnot and it's
very reflective specifically back at the
source of the light you know most lights
they'll like bounce off of a surface or
maybe hit something annual scatter if
it's a very rough material but
retro-reflective stuff the light comes
down and comes right back to sender you
actually see retro-reflective material
all the time but you might not realize
it you know that stop sign that's very
reflective when you shine your high
beams at it that is retroreflective
pretty much all street signs you know
reflective vests tail lights all those
sort of things they have retroreflective
material so that when you're shining
your light beam at it it'll bounce right
back into your eye and this is just a
simple strip of retroreflective tape it
doesn't look that special to you because
these lights that are shining on me
aren't that close to the lens but if we
were to turn one of those lights on
right next to the lens suddenly this
becomes bright
like a reflector we can leverage this to
our advantage by putting this on a
spinning rod on three different sides
and experiment to see how we can make
this appear like a lightsaber
for now i'm not sure how much
retroreflective material we actually
have so i'm going to enlist the help of
our intern to round up what we do have
so we can figure out what we need to get
i like to make sure that my work is
quality which is why i never look up
from when i start doing it i don't look
at anything i always pay attention to
the task in front of me that's how i get
so much [ __ ] done
[Music]
[Applause]
beware my power
your darshan
i just hit myself
oh man it's it is glowing that is cool
you're not even spinning and it's
glowing that's actually pretty sweet so
it's making me question whether or not
we even need it to spin i think you
should shoot it i think
yeah i can put it on a drill and spin it
if you want to see
let me do that
it's cool
oh wait there is i am getting a little
bit of that sort of uh spiraling effect
but it works right yeah i mean it's
totally working and you don't need that
much light just the led wait real quick
real quick
no ready yep yep it's happening
it's happening
i know i know
oh yeah
wait cover the oh there it is
there it is but the more see that gets
rid of
yeah it's getting unstable
[Music]
so i guess the next question is do we
want something perfectly cylindrical or
do we want to have like flat edges on it
so i posit an issue with something
perfectly cylindrical is that when it
spins there's no change in the
silhouette so the flicker isn't going to
happen right the finger is not actually
not a change of brightness flicker it's
a change of size flicker that gives the
appearance of a change brightness you
guys can do something that's like this
yeah actually i mean no no no no other
way opposite yeah something like that
exactly exactly or you can make four
yeah do it as a square
i'm a fan of the three one because i
think that will create the smallest
profile
i think this will create a more unique
sort of reflective pattern so right now
the plan of attack is to actually
fabricate these blades exploring the
different options just to see what it
looks like when it spins once we've
solved that problem then we can try to
solve the problem of how do we get
something that can make it spin look
like a lightsaber
working on this lightsaber project has
got me thinking about the creative
process in general you know like at the
end of the day every tool can be a
hammer because every tool is a hammer
thanks to today's sponsor audible in
adam savage's audio book every tool is a
hammer it's an autobiography from adam
himself but it also tells a lot of very
important lessons about making about
creativity about problem solving and
about using the tools that are available
to you right now
and he tells these lessons through
stories and you know adam he's a great
storyteller he can just talk for days
and he basically does that for eight
straight hours in this audiobook this
book along with thousands of other
titles are available on audible
obviously one of my favorite platforms
they offer a huge library of titles that
you can download and listen to right now
or if you don't want to download them
you can just stream them to your phone
you'll discover all kinds of exclusive
audible originals from top celebrities
or renowned experts and a bunch of new
exciting voices and audio there's a
growing selection of titles included
with your membership that you can listen
to all you want and all you gotta do to
get them is sign up for a free 30-day
trial click that link in the description
or text corridor crew to 500-500
and you'll be able to get any title of
your choice every month again thanks to
audible for sponsoring this episode
audible one of my favorite sponsors of
all time
[Music]
let's take a look at what i got
i picked up some very cheap measuring
tapes of various thicknesses
so that i can cut them up we have some
wooden dowels here we will basically
take our strips of measuring tape cut
them up and glue them to these dowels
and we got some retro reflective tape we
got a nick we got a new workshop look at
it dude grab my top look at the workshop
it rolls on this toe
look at it
[Music]
first i'm going to focus on making sure
we can actually get a retro-reflective
blade
that spins at all once we figure out
that part we'll move on to
actually putting it in this check this
out
does it go all the way inside what is
the deal with that did you have these
toys growing up as a kid yeah and i
hated the ones that don't go all the way
they don't go all the way in and it's so
stupid the last thing i got for this
whole thing is a dremel light um so in
theory this should turn on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah we got to figure out a way to
couple these two things together because
we need to be able to swap out the
blades we can't just have this
permanently affixed
so to make the blades i'm going to need
to cut three lengths of measuring tape
and attach it to this wooden dowel and
then i will put the retroreflective tape
on the measuring tape it's tape city up
in here so i made a prototype blade it's
sweet like this is exactly what we set
out to try to make um the problem that i
started finding is that because of the
retroreflective nature of this it
reflects back from any place it hits
that is what retroflective means yeah
exactly and so what that means is that
as this is spinning it just looks like a
cylinder because it's the silhouette
that matters
so that's why i have a second plan here
so instead of like these types of ideas
here i'm making that one so instead of
having the concave sides facing outwards
i'm going to invert that and have the
round sides facing outwards and i'm only
going to use two the bigger purpose here
is that it actually changes the
silhouette and so my hope is that having
this changing back and forth really
rapidly as it spins would make the
silhouette warble which would achieve
our whole like flickering thing that we
are trying to get so mark while i figure
out a way to actually mount this design
together you can work on your own
version of this design you mentioned
wanting to have it inside of an actual
clear tube so i think now is a great
time for you to try that
this wood is what's known as a soft wood
and it will crumble under pressure and
it will never meet the expectations
of its parents and will
always lead to disappointment
i
think that'll break right away
right away i do
that'll break right away you just drill
a hole into that and then you
take this
and you attach it to the blade
why don't you build your dumb lightsaber
and i'll build my extremely cool way
cooler than your lightsaber you guys
might have to fight lightsabers
it's so wiggly it's a little wiggly
probably do some more reinforcement of
that
oh wow dude
that like fits perfectly
does that work at all
you know it's not actually like hurting
it that much whoa actually it's pretty
sweet it doesn't ruin the effect we got
blue maybe i'll do it because i like
really the problem here is that i've run
out of material
dude do it glue do i think i have to
shift to blue
so this is just a metal rod that i'm
going to use to connect to some plastic
pieces that will then connect to the
dowel so i needed to make sure that this
would actually fit inside of the dremel
and it does so check this out
look at the harmonic frequencies on it
oh yeah look at that look at this like
here's the mode
so i think i need to make some sort of
ring adapter so that this can go inside
of that see how it's just a little loose
now look at this magic shove it up a bit
and that's that
and that'll be as good as it's gonna get
yeah
oh
no
oh
god damn it
good i mean it's kind of it's catching
here it's just catching here yeah it's
all it's in there
you solder those together i i tried
using solder solder did not work i used
super glue instead
this
is going to be glued into that the idea
is that this will go in here i'm going
to have a a drill i have a hole go
through all of this here and this will
go through that
and that'll all be hidden inside of this
now there's a lot of the gap there right
cut this up
this is going to sit on it like
so
oh cool
hey
my lightsaber is grinding its gears
right now
[Music]
see i had to drill a hole on the outside
to get to the hole on the inside
i'm pretty pleased with how this is
coming together
[Music]
yeah this should work
i'm pretty happy
it's uh
it works well it's not supremely agile
but it'll do the job
[Music]
ready
yeah
[Laughter]
you can see the modes
you can see the mode
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna call this done for
now
uh let's go show niko
so i have this to present
like i said
a little rough around the edges but it's
in case it's enclosed it's fairly sturdy
all right let me hit the button don't
worry
wow
it's not rubbing on the sides or
anything nope thankfully i feel like
this is probably more sturdy than the
prop they actually used in the original
star wars i don't know man you swing
that once it'll come apart tell me about
yours
so i wanted to make a modular system
here so we can actually put in different
blades
how's the spin working out for you um i
ran into some unforeseen issues about
three minutes ago
[Music]
wow
don't turn that up too fast
turn it up all the way right no no
it kills it oh i wonder what that looks
like on camera
all right let's see how these look here
we go
so
i need a much brighter light for that
blue to really hit are you sure
are you sure i am sure are you sure i'm
sure but what about
this
it's really interesting like flair look
or like flickering look
oh wow that actually looks
fabulous it looks like darth maul's
lightsaber slash darth vader's
lightsaber however
it's so wiggly that it kind of lowers
the exposure on it when it's standing
still it's hyper bright
it actually looks like a straight up
lightsaber when it's standing still
not too bad not too bad not too bad all
right all right mark if you could step
if you step in
i'll never join you
[Music]
i like i like mark's flutter
i like ren's brightness i think we have
a situation where mark put in a lot of
industrial design into his lightsaber
and i really like how his protective
casing on it and the compact handle also
very classy i think ren looked out and
picking the better reflective tape
[Laughter]
you know it was actually wren that said
to make a blue one so he sabotaged me ah
ren why'd you do that
don't
stop that you're off the jedi order
[Laughter]
give me one more go i got i got high
hopes for this one
oh yeah that looks nice
that's a saver yeah now we're talking
it's not spinning his best because it's
not as the tolerances are all over the
place it's just very
you might have heard hammering back
there
here's what i like to do you guys have
made some awesome lightsaber prototypes
i'd like to set up a nicer digital
cinema camera and just get some cool
shots and like see how cool can make
this look like let's show people
what actual practical lightsabers look
like and how dynamic they can really be
[Music]
the coolest thing about these
lightsabers
is that when you guys are moving them
they're hyper dynamic with like the glow
and the color and the motion blur and
all that stuff you don't get like the
movie motion blur which is just one big
color fan you get like the actual
dynamic like burns that you get with
like hot light on like sensors where
it's like
dark red orange to weird yellow to white
none of the lightsabers come close in
the movies they're all just punched out
in hot spots
[Music]
so listen it's kind of jank i made this
in a couple days and i'm still pretty
proud of it this was a very very fun
project it was an experiment from the
beginning to end despite it not being
perfect the fact that we got results at
all that were cool is the best but one
of the things mark and i were talking
about were ways to perhaps incorporate
just a single string of leds along one
side and having that emit light into the
scene like the modern lightsabers do we
just didn't have enough time to figure
out how to power it and have it actually
still spin but that is something that
i'm hoping to see some of you perhaps
try you know i am now delivering the
mental of responsibility to you to
create the most effective in-camera
lightsaber effect possible i feel like
we got most of the way there i love
doing this type of thing if you have any
ideas for the sort of like practical
versus digital effects that we can try
to tackle ourselves leave a comment down
below i will be reading through all of
them just trying to get some ideas it's
hard coming out with new videos every
week so anyway yeah thanks for watching
and also thanks to markiplier of all
people who helped build our new workshop
here so hopefully i'll be back getting
my hands dirty more frequently with some
more project builds anyway i'm really
excited for the future
the end and i'll see you next time